my managers were just like um hey Judd
Apatow just called and asked if you
wanted to write for crashing and I was
like yes yeah I do and I just remember
like this is incredible you know like my
life will change because of this because
it's very difficult to get a writing job
and you know I had done a couple Judd at
that time he had seen me out a lot
because he was starting to get back into
stand-up and so as you we saw his
special came out last Christmas time
that's what he was working towards but
like that's why his reinvestment in
stand-up and in Pete's show and all that
inspired him to start doing stand-up
again I'm sure among other things but
from my viewpoint and talking with him
so he saw him he was out on the scene
getting back into it and he saw me and I
had been on the Pete Holmes show and I
knew pee and so when it came to hiring
writers they just they thought of me and
I I went into to write for it so what
does a typical day look like on the
writing you get in you have coffee one
time usually around 9:00 okay yeah
reasonable yes sometimes we'd start
early
and then you already start thinking
about lunch it's a lot of ordering food
it's a lot of ordering food and coffee
but yeah I mean the ideal early
processes are what but the early stages
I should say are like well what they
would call like blue sky so you're just
sort of pitching things out in a sort of
brainstorming way sharing stories and
stuff where where the show could go you
know from your own life and you know
just commiserating but also sharing
group experience and a lot of us have
been to the same comedy clubs and so we
know the owners we share our different
stories about that you know and all the
things that could happen and there
there's a writer's assistant in the room
who usually that person is wants to be a
writer and they work extremely hard and
they're paid the least and you know they
do a lot of work because they're
organizing everybody's thoughts and
taking them down in real time Josh yes
a writer's assistant is a very very
tough job I think there's somewhat hard
to get and like I said they worked so
hard and they're paid the least
and so they're they're taking everything
down and then those notes will go out
and you can you know review them over
the you know overnight if you want it
the next day come in and as weeks go on
in the early stages you're sort of
trying to map out the season you know
episodes whatever how many episodes your
show is but for us one through eight and
sort of the arc of the season and the
characters and all of those things they
start to take form as the week's go on
and we sort of lock things in and Judd
would pop he's not there every single
day but he sort of pop in sorry it's so
loud no you're okay these mics will pick
up man oh good good okay yeah this is
companies the grind right here I know
but Judd would sort of come in and
basically sort of shape or hone in on
the ideas or basically share his
expertise like here's where I think this
should go and sometimes we'd be going
off on a tangent for a long time and if
he didn't pop in for a while he could
come in and be like no he would never be
like no you know he's not like that he
would just be like what if it goes in
this direction or I think the series
isn't like for season one I remember
he's like what if it ends with Leif and
Pete and Abed together and then so we
would have to sort of find our way to
that even if even if that's not where we
were going at all so we were suffering
so yeah he's I mean he's the executive
producer so he has pretty much the final
says almost like one of those tent poles
though yeah like you said like with your
stand up you like here's where we need
to get oh yeah
the destination yeah he want he had a
vision for how he wanted the season to
end and how we were gonna get there was
our the task and how many hours a day is
this usually it depends on your
showrunner like their style and you know
sometimes if they feel like well you're
exhausted we've exhausted our minds
today you can go home hmm
it depends but you know there are shows
I know for a fact I hear these stories
about like oh the new girl room was
really long they would be there
sometimes overnight you know her stayed
till 11:00 or midnight and with crashing
it was typically like 9:00 or 10:00 2:00
to 6:00 ish you know something like that
so like decent hours sometimes early or
sometimes later I've heard Pete say
in interviews with crashing specifically
in writing it that uh he felt like if
what they were talking about didn't make
him uncomfortable or didn't feel too
personal to share then almost wasn't
worth keeping mm-hmm do you find the
same with your material or things that
you write as well or did you find that
in the show or yeah I mean I think it's
like you your desire obviously is to
connect with mind desires to connect
with people first and foremost but in my
own very unique way and so I mean I'm
not calling myself very unique but I'm
saying ideally I'm connecting with them
in a unique way you know I don't I don't
want it to be I like the specificity of
things you know and so my favorite
things early on and stand up were when I
would see a comic talking about
something very very specific and me
knowing exactly what they were talking
about it just made me laugh so hard and
that was my favorite thing about it it's
like how could they and those are the
moments we were like man I wish I
thought of that those those times where
you see jokes that you're basically
jealous of because you're like that's so
good why didn't I so really all you're
trying to do is just get that unique
perspective on topics that really a lot
of people can relate to you know and
then again not everyone is going to like
you and I think that's probably a good
thing in my opinion it hurts a little
because a lot of us are you know either
star for attention or we're in this for
a reason because we need that like sort
of love from the outside so it can hurt
a little if not everybody likes what you
do but I think in general it's probably
I would prefer having a specific group
of people than everyone do you think
that's helped you to find your voice as
well like you say yeah right I don't
like I guess I maybe I would be fooling
myself to say that I don't love creating
some tension you know I think I do I
think too for a long time it was one of
those things where it's like you just
you want to you don't want to stir
things up or whatever or have like a
super strong opinion because because you
want to be liked and
that was obviously a theme for me as a
kid as like a little performer an
attention seeker like I wanted to be
liked and obviously I still have that in
me as a stand-up you know I enjoy
getting laughs but now I think I have
more of a desire to say what's on my
mind or or or make a sort of statement
or a point or share my perspective on it
you know yeah and maybe open up somebody
else's mind to it yeah so I don't
necessarily want to be like you know I'm
a super political comic I'm not at least
I don't I mean I don't see myself that
way but I would like to shake open up
somebody's eyes to a different
perspective
[Music]
I breath